i don't know if you guys remember but um
about a year ago there was a movement
that
called itself i guess classical
liberalism
which claimed to be part of some new
center of american politics and in
reality it was a complete and total
ruse what they wanted to do
was to sort of normalize wacky
libertarian conservatism as if it were
the new center of american politics when
it really wasn't the new center of
american politics but
just because that movement was wrong in
identifying a new center
doesn't mean that there isn't an
identifiable new center and that's what
i want to talk about today and i think
the context that will be relevant and
interesting here is that
if we on the left want to keep
moving ourselves to the left as a
country
we want to understand the areas in which
the
average of the country would be
liable to side with us rather than to be
pulled further to the right now i
i i don't know if this is necessary but
as a quick disclaimer before we jump
into this
this new center that i'm going to
describe to you these are not
my views i need to i know that if i
don't do this i will have a hundred
messages tomorrow from people saying
david you centrist
shill it is i i know we're not used to
it with donald trump who's
who's unable to do any kind of uh
abstract thinking
but i'm going to describe to you a set
of beliefs that is not mine so
these are not my beliefs i'm to the left
of this new
center uh now that being said let's get
into the details gallup did a very
interesting study which they've done for
20 to 40 years on different issues
and they looked at where is the country
right now
on a variety of different issues and
they've represented
the issues as well as the shift in
opinion
visually and we're putting that up on
the screen for our visual audience but
i'm also going to describe it to you and
this lets us build up a sort of picture
of where the middle is right now in
america on a number of issues so let's
go
through the eight issues so on on gun
sales
the center the the average of the
country right now the middle
wants more strict gun sales laws than
those that we've had in the past
the center believes that religion is
fairly important but not
very important the center thinks that
military spending is about right
believes the earth should be prioritized
over the economy
and that immigration law should more or
less stay the same in terms of the
number of immigrants coming into the
united states
the center as of today thinks that the
federal income tax is just about right
they don't think it should be raised but
they don't think it should be lowered
that abortion should be legal sometimes
but not always
and that marijuana should be legalized
so remember this is just
an average of the middle but what's
extremely
interesting about this is that it proves
that the new center
is not libertarian it is not classically
liberal and you really need to look at
the details to understand this new
center as an example
if the new center were merely
libertarian it wouldn't favor stricter
gun laws
for example it wouldn't favor
prioritizing the earth over the economy
because that is code for
we've got to regulate business activity
if the center
were libertarian it wouldn't think
immigration laws were just about right
because true libertarians want total
mobility of labor and that's not what we
currently have
what's also important to understand
about
how we came to this new center is how
opinion on these eight issues has
shifted over time so
again looking at one example in the
early 90s
much of the gun laws should be made more
strict
that changed until 2010 when people
wanted looser and looser gun laws
and then since 2010 we've seen a
reversal
which has very strongly returned to the
early 90s numbers where
the center wants stricter gun laws so
does the left as well
religion has been much more steady in
its change over time the center of
america
has found religion less and less
important over time where it now finds
it
fairly but not very important military
spending
has moved pretty erratically often in
concert with what's going on
militarily at the time and then
interestingly if you look at the trends
on immigration
it is very steady over the last 40 years
that immigration to the united states
should should generally speaking be
increased
ending up sort of at its okay where it
is
and then probably not surprisingly on
marijuana
it's been a steady increase in the
proportion of americans that believe
cannabis should be legalized so
why do we care about this again if we
want to build the left
we must understand where the center is
if we misunderstand where the center is
we are not going to properly structure
our platform the center is not
some small government pro-business
conservative the way we would sometimes
be
be uh convinced mitt romney
is not the center mitt romney is far
more reasonable than donald trump
mitt romney is far less offensive and
dangerous than donald trump but mitt
romney is not the center and that's
important to understand
when the left thinks the center is
something that it's not
it tries to appeal to the center in the
wrong ways
so let me know what you think i think
that this new center
represents a lot of the changes we've
been following in the united states
which would include
a sort of status quo perspective on some
issues and a progressivization
on other issues let me know what you
think let me know importantly
how you think our understanding of this
new center could be used
to bring more people to us to our side
and to really push
progressive change